i was waiting for him to move but
actually i've just realized i'm playing
white
okay okay okay let's develop
oh everyone is playing ragosa now what
is it like why why is did anish did it
to the entire world everyone is playing
regularly nowadays
even me from time to time so isri
where is the where is the hero the
the zero it's a rook c1
and now s3 is coming um
okay so bishop uh yeah what what should
he do now
cdxd5 is in there but uh
is kc-6s5 which will be three to go for
queen c2
well i've developed better here guess
what it's better but
okay show page four
like to play for some g4 at some point
but
yeah it goes in batman 2017 is a good
opening of course but i just mean that
everybody's playing like this
pizzan says tamar please play queen's
gambit against a girl
here not me i'll try to i'll try to
maybe not this time but i'll try to play
against the girl
the queen's gambit i'm actually playing
the queen's gambit myself as black
in classical tournaments but
no
not as good looking as the actors in the
netflix series
okay this is uh queen up i feel i can do
a lot of
a lot of good things with the queen up
here
queen g4
oh by the way is it supposed to be the
last game or